[Music]
hey guys and welcome back to monster
maze in my previous video together with
Nintendo black crisis we presented a
general idea of how a traditional
dungeon could work in the sequel to
breath the wild giving sort of an
overview of all the different aspects
that make a dungeon fun to play through
as well as some of the problems that
need to be overcome to make the new
mechanics introduced in breath the wild
work together with the more traditional
game design from the older games if you
haven't watched it yet I highly
recommend that you do check that one out
first before moving on as this one will
go a little bit deeper in some of the
points I covered in that video now this
video is going to be a little bit more
freeform and less scripted as I want to
try to explain my thought process a bit
quicker so without further ado let's get
into it in the previous video you may
have noticed a few snippets of this
quote-unquote hypothetical dungeon now
please keep in mind this is not meant to
be a fully realized level by any means
I basically slap this thing together in
a little over two days as you can
clearly see from this amazing texture
work also architectural II speaking this
place makes very little sense like where
would these broken pillars even have
been attached to or what is the purpose
of all these moving platforms it's a
video game level not much else but aside
from the amateur istic look I did
actually think about how you would be
moving through this structure and the
various ways that you can restrict a
player from progressing too easily but
without taking climbing and paragliding
away entirely one thing to mention up
front and don't quote me on this because
I might be completely wrong but I'm
going to guess that the champion
abilities like Rivoli's Gale are no
longer thing in the sequel all these
abilities were tied to the champion
spirits I mean you can even see the
manifest when you use them and at the
end of the game we can clearly see that
they move on to the afterlife and
honestly I think removing these
abilities from the game would be for the
better as memphis grace alone was pretty
opie in my opinion it's like a fairy but
on steroids the first thing to note
about this dungeon idea is that this
outer wall around the dungeon should
either not
or be made on climb aboard there is
unfortunately the sacrifice we do have
to make to make this example work since
if it was climb aboard Varitek and
slippery or whatever I don't actually
see anything wrong with restricting
climbing on certain surfaces
it's just that in breath the wild it was
a little bit inconsistent like why can I
climb these ice crystals which shouldn't
provide any grip at all but I cannot
climb these very rough looking walls
inside of the divine beast for the sake
of demonstration I'm actually gonna hide
this outer wall for now as it will make
my life a lot easier moving the camera
around as you can see this dungeon is
built around that idea of vertical
traversal I talked so much about in the
previous video where a large part of the
complexity is derived from how you are
going to progress upwards I like this
concept for two reasons one is that it
forces you to be observant about your
surroundings and study the space around
you and two because similar to a dungeon
likes a city in the sky
it just feels awesome to scale these
enormous Heights in real life I don't
really have a fear of heights but I'm
not exactly comfortable with them either
as evident from this clip right here
where I had to shoot footage for a
construction company from atop a 70
meter high crane let's just say that my
legs were shaking a fair bit this tower
design is very reminiscent of the snow a
temple or the water temple with a
central pillar that just goes up and up
accompanied by all these sideway paths
leading into other rooms
obviously the ideas that you start from
the bottom and work your way up
gradually so this right here would be
the entrance first let's go over the
different ways of restricting the player
from simply climbing up and reaching the
top prematurely the first and most
simple one being the use of an overhang
in breath the wild if parts of the wall
stick out too far horizontally you won't
be able to progress up link might be
spider-man but even he has his limits
the second one is on climb above
surfaces as mentioned before this could
be a wall that is either too slippery
because of water or ice or in the case
of this example I used iron bars if
you've ever visited Hyrule castles lock
up you might have noticed you won't be
able to climb those the third option
would be a surface that
actually deals damage and knocks you off
if you get into contact with it
which in the case of this example I used
spikes and I think in the previous video
I also gave an example of a tile that
electrocute you for instance it would
kind of depend on the theme of the
dungeon of course all these methods
combined can prevent link from
progressing up way too easily every
floor has been barred off so you can
only access the parts that you are
supposed to so for instance when you
reach this part right here you won't be
able to use your paraglider to reach
this section hence the spikes or cheat
your way around this platforming section
because of the overhang the idea is that
you hop your way from platform to
platform cling on to this one and then
jump to the next one as soon as they
align and boom you're there then you
hold on to the other side of this
rotating wall to reach the platform on
the other side and then you climb your
way up this wall while avoiding these
moving spikes to reach this platform
right here and from here you can
parrot-like down to the next level
progressing up is again restricted by
this overhang and these bars and from
this level you cannot access any other
place you haven't already been to the
only way up is through to the roof of
this structure right here but how well
this is what I meant by forcing the
player to be observant about their
surroundings when you were still on the
bottom floor near the entrance you might
have been able to see that this ledge
right here has a gap in it and by
putting two and two together you will
understand that you can climb around
this wall and up to the roof I put like
a rope here similar to Skyward Sword and
Twilight Princess but honestly this
could have been anything another bridge
or a small stair this was either me
being lazy or wanting to mix it up and
who knows maybe tightrope walking will
become a thing again from this point the
path splits you can either try to enter
this room right here or climb the ladder
to the next floor to any of these three
rooms some are barred some are locked
and honestly this is where I stopped
carrying how he would exactly progress
further I put some random chests here
and there but this project was already
getting out of hand so they are mostly
there for show obviously any of these
rooms could hold a combat challenge or a
puzzle like the ones we encountered in
the shrines oh and this part right here
with the pillars that's where
one of the gameplay options I talked
about previously could be used namely
jumping from wall to wall I actually
tested this out in breath the wild and
if the walls are close enough together
it actually is doable there are some
problems with the camera which
automatically tries to Center behind
link when he clinks the next wall and
the controls are a bit funky since it
doesn't matter from which perspective
you are looking at the situation you
always have to press down and jump to
perform this move which is a bit
counterintuitive however they could
simply fix this with a new input perhaps
pressing the jump button twice in rapid
succession to perform a wall jump just
spitballing here from this point I
really have nowhere else to go in terms
of progression so let's talk about
something I haven't touched upon as of
yet dungeon items as you might have
noticed from my previous video I love me
some hook shot just the idea that you
can paraglide around and target a wall
pull yourself towards it is just amazing
to me I do realize that if the hook shot
is implemented this whole vertical
design pretty much goes out the window
as from that point on there's little
ways to go but linear maze like
room-to-room dungeon design as anything
with a vertical design like this would
be completely destroyed by the ability
to target any wall or object so if
anything this should either be one of
the last items to be introduced in the
game or the surfaces that you are
allowed to target are little bit more
limited in my first video I used Just
Cause as an example but I imagine that
there are so many more cool items that
could be introduced in breadth a while
too so in that case let's have a little
brainstorming session together sound off
in the comments below if you have a cool
idea regarding an item old or new that
could make it into breath the wild - and
who knows I might even compile them and
include them in a future video with that
said I think I have reached a point
where you all get the idea the sequel to
breath the wild has a lot of potential
and a lot of options when it comes to
integrating the traditional dungeon
design I'm pretty sure that speedrunners
will have a field day with the dungeon
idea like the one I just presented and
completely break it on every conceivable
level as they have done so many times in
the past games in the next episode we
are going to switch gears a bit and look
something else the loam a labyrinths
found in breath the wild and see if
these structures could potentially make
a return in the next game as well as
analyzing their architecture I hope you
look forward to it
I was actually planning to do a 100
subscriber milestone mention in this
video but by this point I already
surpassed 300 subscribers so I'm gonna
save it for the 1000 milestone thank you
all so very much for your support
I never expected my video to do so well
if you want to support me all you need
to do is subscribe to the channel and if
you're feeling even more generous leave
a like on the video this is Don signing
off and have a good one ah man it's
raining again I am not paying money for
a bed so I can skip the time what don't
worry it's perfectly safe oh whoops